I am developing feelings for Alan just
one week after Alexis Ren admitted she
was falling for her Dancing with the
Stars Pro partner Alan Burstyn Alan
revealed he feels the same I do have
feelings for you and I really do like
[Applause]
[Music]
you finally opened up tonight you said
you were falling for her good at opening
up why do it tonight I mean I didn't
want to leave her hanging I'm kidding
I'm kidding no I mean I mean it was
horseback riding this beautiful is it's
not right the horseback riding was
romantic I was a personal scared of the
horses I don't scare to that moment what
does make you fall for her like what
qualities does she have you know even
when it's hard she doesn't give up and I
really like persistence and I like
determination I like passion now that we
had this talking this week I feel really
good that everything that
[Music]
what was it like watching that kiss back
it was your first time guys kiss I mean
I was we were focusing on the dance we
have a bad habit of every time that
there's a package is it hard to watch
them back a little bit cuz you feel like
you're being so vulnerable absolutely a
lot of the time I'm like please don't
watch the package and I'm telling myself
I'm like just don't watch the package
get ready for the dance literally in
this package I said how embarrassing
it's hard to do stuff on TV
staring at you and you're just like I'm
just oh my heart it's weird what are you
guys in a kiss in the ballroom I think
that's enough I think that's all the
time we have for today Entertainment
Tonight the couples chemistry was
electric during their samba performance
on country night
[Music]
[Applause]
what do you guys make of tonight the
judges literally are obsessed with you I
think you know what it's very nice to
hear from Len that Alexis had one of the
best dances of the night especially the
Samba is so hard it was a very stressful
week just because I was trying to drill
everything inside you know like make
sure she's bouncing make sure the hips
are moving make sure she looks confident
and you know what she did she did a
great job and I'm super happy what do
you guys make of tonight's double
elimination I mean finally two guys went
home but still so you know what it's
honestly it's a bittersweet it's a
bittersweet because we were in in
jeopardy for the first time but it's
it's it's it sucks that DeMarcus and Jon
had to leave because they're such good
energies and they always make everyone
smile and it's just we're gonna miss him
but there's only one more week which is
night they'll be back for the finale I
know I can't believe it
how does the game plan change evolve you
know I think this is the last
competitive you know this is like last
Korra we got to give it everything we
have adding even more pressure
it seems alexis is still nursing some
injuries to fraction Rosie fractured
another one the other side I like drove
myself to the hospital bwick it's fine
I'm fine
and the doctor came in laughs and he was
like there's a same doctor is the first
thing I'd like you did it again
you drove yourself blood urgent care
Urgent Care Hospital Hospital sounds bad
I'm gonna choreograph stuff
[Applause]